a digital first approach to the future
of work is where the industry and all
companies will be heading put the future
of work not be at home or in the office
but in the metaverse instead
there's that word
metaverse going well how are you doing
when i think about the metaverse i think
about immersive experiences that have a
sense of active presence wow look at
this
this is me
the metaverse is projected to become
over a trillion dollar market by the end
of this decade
and whether you know it or not you'll
probably be working there in the future
we're moving into a world where we're
going to be interacting with computers
with our bodies this is definitely
trippy i think the adoption curve is
going to be slow it's a weird weird
floaty thing right now oh look at you it
might have no legs it's kind of a fun
world and we're just at the very
beginning of a very long journey
now to properly tell this story i felt
it was important that i a never leave my
home and b spend a bit more time in the
metaverse myself
so i got a vr headset
tried it on
checked it out a little bit i actually
feel like this is what i should look
like all the time and found someone
who's been immersed in ar vr commonly
combined and referred to as xr since the
beginning oh it says he's here what up
uh
talking about me my name is ken fine i
do the voices of your podcast there's a
sauna that's upstairs we did a scout for
the right place to do the interview
we considered a hot tub
it feels great but ultimately we chose
this quiet and comfortable lounge
complete with the fireplace
we even created a virtual three-camera
shoot with my colleagues tom and jordan
i am rolling it's the gang we're getting
the band back together i'm rolling on my
end um cool all right yeah take it away
i mean it's just the whole idea of the
avatar i find that interesting
especially in the context of work and
meeting people that we choose how we're
going to be represented i mean i don't
know if i would be a ragdoll bunny
rabbit driving a robot
in any other context what's happening is
impacting your emotions in some ways you
know we're in these avatars and we have
a sense of embodied presence but you
know we can have the virtual body
ownership illusion where you start to
really own this body that you have when
you have that full commitment
kent's obviously much better at this
than me you can tell how his hands move
really naturally when he talks whereas
mine well they fidgeted and mostly just
kind of folded in on themselves let me
ask you how did the pandemic change our
concept of meeting and the onset of the
pandemic
you had all this technology with skype
and zoom and everything that had been
out there as infrastructure for a long
time but most people would prefer to
meet and have that full rich embodied
interaction but after the pandemic
pretty much everybody you could meet
with and so it actually kind of
democratized access to different people
and i think vr is kind of placed to kind
of
be in this next phase as we move forward
you know we're having this conversation
right now where you didn't have to come
out to portland oregon but we can still
you know recreate the essence of what
would happen if you would be here
this concept is being adopted by a
multitude of companies whose research
has found that fully simulated
environments of immersive learning help
their trainees retain information better
as it gives them a stronger sense of
place and a more memorable experience
overall
accenture is a huge consulting company i
hire anywhere from like 60 to 100 000
people a year they've purchased 60 000
quests to be able to send out to be able
to do onboarding into their company
whoa
wait a second but what little time i've
spent in vr i couldn't help but feel
like it's more of an escape rather than
a place to work
and if i'm going to step into an
alternate reality i want to fly around
play games and do things that aren't
possible in the real world which doesn't
really include taking meetings
i often find within a lot of those
workplaces they have the most amazing
technology in the world and then you're
in a world that just makes you feel like
you're in a soulless corporate office
and you go in there and you're like i
totally don't want to be in this space
nevertheless there is a mad dash in the
tech sector to create virtual spaces
that are conducive to work and some of
the largest companies are leading the
charge
as you probably already know facebook
rebranded to meta signaling their
intention to lead in this new virtual
world
so i got myself a slightly more buttoned
up smoother and younger looking avatar
with much better hair whoa
that's kind of me
to check in with meta's senior product
director micah collins i assume that you
believe that this is the future of work
is that correct
i believe it is a part of the future of
work i think what companies and
employees need is a new common
collaboration platform
i remember how long we used to travel
for a 30-minute meeting and take the red
eye back home it's crazy to think about
ever having to do something like that
again we want to essentially allow a new
culture around collaboration to emerge
where people can kind of be however
they're comfortable build a very
inclusive product that still fosters
options and the ability to be as present
as you want to be so
barcelona
the gamification of reality has blurred
those lines of what work really is how
you get work done
why are we actually limiting ourselves
uh and constraining ourselves to an
office environment in the metaverse
helping it feel like a place for work is
a key part is it familiar enough where
we can feel like it's something new be
inspired to be here but not be
completely distracted by it so we don't
actually get anything done i think it is
that balance of like building something
special but also building it for a
purpose with intention to ultimately
help us focus
let's not forget that meetings aren't
always just talk
fields like architecture product design
or fabrication require hands-on
collaborations something that xr is
poised to take particular advantage of
what does it look like to sketch a new
sneaker design together what does it
look like to
review something that's being designed
how do we think about things like 3d
object import from creation applications
and tools that designers use so that we
can actually sit down and
have people look at something together
and redline it in space together and
then export it for continued development
video conferences can be mentally
exhausting many of us are also
experiencing a heightened level of
anxiety and fatigue
but just as there's zoom fatigue there's
most certainly bound to be xr fatigue in
fact i kind of already have it
and as intriguing as all this is my head
kind of hurts my eyes are tired and in
reality not every meeting is necessarily
going to have to be this immersive there
may be a headset on my desk that's ready
to go at any point in time let me start
the meeting in vc while i wrap up some
text and do some other things then all
of a sudden it's like oh now it's time
to put on my headset
and go fully propelled and immersive
into the space we want to take that
friction
away
from moving between different connection
modalities and just make it really
up to the user
but as a new adopter let me just say we
are not there yet
the utopia is that it's seamless but you
know let me throw a number at you right
now the average large company uses 188
different apps 188 i mean that's kind of
insane
we have tech overload right now
we're still not even getting zoom calls
right can you hear me judge
i can hear you i think it's a filter i'm
here live that's not i'm not a cat
we're still screwing those up left right
and center and you have people who feel
excluded you have workers who are going
into the office and spending all day on
zoom and saying why did i schlep all the
way into the office just to spend my day
on zoom there's going to be cool
experiments of course there always are
but you know in terms of this being how
we work i think we're a little bit far
from that right now
the adoption curve is going to be slow
it's going to be painful it's going to
be expensive companies are already
spending millions of dollars on new
benefits to keep employees happy and
engaged so they don't quit so now
telling them what we've got to be
investing in the metaverse as well
they're going to say well what's the
payoff why should we be doing this
back in the old-fashioned physical world
a bit north of silicon valley microsoft
has been actively trying to solve these
more practical problems in what they
deem the hybrid workplace a more
equitable convergence of the remote and
office worlds
when you think of meetings in the future
almost every interaction that you have
in person is also going to have some
sort of digital person joining that
they're going to be on the other side
digitally participating and so you kind
of have to design your physical space
for people who aren't physically there
it's our mission to make sure that
remote interactions are not second class
interactions that they're first class
that anytime we bring together the
digital with the physical that we really
have a very rich you know multi-faceted
interaction that doesn't advantage or
disadvantage anyone because if we can
tap into talent from all over the world
if you don't have to physically be next
to someone in order to make a difference
in an organization or in order to make
sure that your idea is used man imagine
what we can do you know for the planet
for the human family really
this rethinking of the modern meeting
includes a complete reconfiguration of
everything from technology interfaces
and multiple camera angles to room sizes
and even table shapes
ultimately what we found is that the
most important thing is that you have to
kind of balance people seeing and
interacting with each other physically
and also being seen by the digital
participants and so we have come to
shapes like you see here that allow
cameras to be able to create a separate
video feed for each of the physical
participants that we can then beam over
to people who are attending virtually
that ends up being the sweet spot right
there
of course microsoft is still betting
that xr will be a part of this future
their version of meta's metaverse is
called mesh
they also have an ambitious mixed
reality headset the hololens
the adoption of which has yet to be wide
enough to project any dominance in the
market at least partially due to its
very high price tag
and that very well may be where apple
comes in apple is the elephant in the
room when it comes to virtual meetings
virtual reality and augmented reality
the company for about seven years now
has been working on a vr headset or a
mixed reality headset an augmented
reality headset they have people from
nasa they have people from the video
game industry they have people from
hollywood they have people who worked on
the original you know macs iphones ipads
apple watches
leading the design of this project from
a software standpoint a hardware
standpoint a content standpoint
with apple's reputation for relatively
affordable consumer products there's
little doubt that whatever they drop
will alter the landscape of the
metaverse
but while the older kids fight amongst
themselves in the great text sandbox in
the sky we mustn't forget that the
metaverse remains anyone's game there's
a diverse set of visions out there that
could easily have an impact on the
workplace of the future and many of them
don't involve ar vr or any kind of mixed
reality at all
desktop versions of meeting places can
achieve similar results without the
adoption issues or infrastructure
requirements of vr headsets and the like
what we find is companies that are maybe
vr first
there's that novel kind of cool factor
but not many people have headsets yet
that's why we're desktop first
application verbella is betting that
physical offices of any kind are a thing
of the past offering an entire virtual
campus complete with everything from
private offices to convention halls
auditoriums music venues yoga studios
soccer fields we even took a boat ride
once you drive
oh wow
we see environments like this becoming
kind of the hub where large
organizations can come together and have
this united place of this is our
headquarters
when the pandemic hit we were about
20 employees and today we're
closer to 140.
everyone here is hundreds if not
thousands of miles from one another yet
present together in this virtual campus
nice casual place to me
space gives us again these social cues
the ability to sit even though obviously
our avatars aren't getting tired
we see people getting territorial about
their space
at one point we crashed a conference and
opened the floor up to commons i asked
people to tell me where they were
physically and they were indeed
thousands of miles away from each other
wait who's working from disney
world wow that is completely insane well
thanks everybody thanks for letting us
interrupt the meeting here
just the idea that someone could clock
in work hours while at the magic kingdom
kind of blew my mind
here was someone able to balance work
and pleasure in a way that was
unthinkable a few years prior
but after about two hours inside this
campus i couldn't help but recall what
kent told me about the state of virtual
workplaces you're in a world that just
makes you feel like you're in a soulless
corporate office you go in there and
you're like i
totally don't want to be in this space
whereas i do get the idea that work
needs to stay grounded in some sort of
analog of reality there's a part of me
that just wants to abandon all
constraints of the physical world
and that thinking led me quite literally
nowhere
what's up buddy welcome to nowhere this
is a virtual 3d metaverse platform
but nowhere we're not about recreating
reality like by putting buildings and
office rooms and board spaces we're
about creating environments that really
inspire different emotions and different
feelings about how do you want to feel
when you're in these environments
actually why don't i take you to where i
love to have my meetings
nice here we go
nowhere embraces magical realism as its
backdrop it's decidedly avatar free
web-based and for lack of a better word
kind of anti-vr
instead they've constructed a platform
that takes the best of both video
conferencing and virtual spaces
for us
there's nothing like the presence of of
humans when you're on a zoom call it's
just a flat grid you know you see the
people's faces but there's no sense of
presence but within nowhere you have
that added sense of place that allows
you to create memories you know we're
looking at each other we're able to see
all the subtlety of facial expression
which is based on thousands and
thousands of years of evolution of us
instinctually you know looking for signs
of how we read people's faces of how we
read people's body behavior when i'm in
vr i feel a disconnect from people and i
feel disconnect from the world you know
some of my most exciting moments in life
are when i'm with humans
i don't believe that cartoon avatars are
going to create the feeling of
co-presence and the feeling of intimacy
that we need within work environments to
trust each other to collaborate freely
and to really build relationships that
build great teams that build great
products
regardless of john's hardline stance on
avatars it seems obvious that xr is not
going away
the ar vr in mixed reality sectors
combined is expected to grow into a
hundred billion dollar market by 2025
and with the availability of more
affordable headsets adoption is really a
matter of when not if the next paradigm
is really these augmented reality mixed
reality and virtual reality ecosystems
and right now it seems that meta is
going to be at the forefront
so you're going to see a wide array of
people probably using those meta
headsets for video conferencing more
people at home will be able to get their
hands on it and at some point apples
become a big deal too for the future of
virtual work
i'm still wrapping my head around all of
this
vr and the like fully replacing our
physical reality isn't likely to happen
anytime soon
but as alternative realities of every
type seep into our homes and offices be
them virtual or otherwise it's safe to
say that this will not be our last
meeting in the metaverse
guys this has been really fun i think we
should i think we should do this again
[Music]
you